you're not getting Shadow banned you
just suck at social media right like let
me tell you who I'm excited for that's
in this audience is the creative class
the creative class here now does not
have to rely on Gatekeepers deciding
that their story about their Heritage
their gender their interests like now
you can put that out people love to
on social networks it's free
distribution it is free distribution and
nobody decides if your content is
quality or not it is the most
meritocracy reality in the world the
algorithms are getting even better
people are going to start blaming the
algorithm for their stuff not being seen
no let me help you nobody wants to watch
your stuff
once you get there and realize that's
not bad that's actually phenomenal then
you start deploying humility against the
stories you want to tell you start to
tweak it you start to try to make it for
the audience and you might be able to
break through then rendering bigger
platforms like yourselves and others to
have interest